my nephew had a dream at one point this
little someone made a little animated
thing out of it and put it on the
internet which is quite cool so anyways
he he was having night terrors and he
ran around like a little night you know
ki a kanay get K ni ght night and he had
a little you know armor and the sword
and he run around the house with little
night hat on being the knight and he was
only like four or something and he
watched his lot of Disney movies a lot
of movies so he kind of got the night
idea was good it was that he's acting
that out and he was having these terrors
at night right so he'd go to bed with
his this little night tap and his sword
and he put him on his bed and then at
night he'd wake up screaming and that
happened for a very long time and so
when I went to visit you know I found
out that this was happening and he had
night terror so the kid wakes up with
night terrors screaming but can't
remember anything generally speaking so
anyways this was happening and so what
happened one day and and I was sitting
with him and his family at the at the
breakfast table and I said did you did
you have a dream and he said oh yes I
had a dream I said well we know what was
your dream and he said well I was out on
this field and and and I was surrounded
by these dwarfs and they came up to my
knees and they were they didn't have any
arms they had big feet and they were
covered with hair there was a cross
shaved at the top of their head and they
were all greasy and they had huge beaks
and everywhere I went they jumped at me
with their beaks and there was lots of
them and everybody was very quiet after
he said this because it was like not oh
that's why you're screaming at night
it's like yeah okay and so so and the
end and then he said but but at the
background there was a dragon and the
dragon would blow out smoke and fire and
then it would turn into these dwarfs so
it's like man that kid had a problem
right it was like well what are you
gonna do he fight off a dwarf who cares
it's like pops Kenmore that's life man
that's life really that's the Hydra you
cut off one head seven more grow that's
life snakes everywhere and you get rid
of one there'll be more and so he
figured
that out hell of an existential shock
when you're four and so he's like he's a
knight he's thinking what do I do about
these Dwarfs well there's too many of
them but there's a dragon
also I said well what could you do about
that right loaded question it implies
that you could do something about that
well he kind of knew that which is why
he was running around like a knight he
kind of figured that out and he said
well I get my dad when I jump up on the
dragon and I poke out both of its eyes
with my sword and and I go right down
its stomach to the place where the fire
came out the fire box and then I carve a
piece of the fire box out if I make a
shield and that would be the end of that
and I thought wow good work kid like you
really got it right it's the it's the
central human story there's a terrible
unknown right fire-breathing generating
trouble and what do you do you confront
that you confront that and by
confronting it you get stronger
that's the shield and that's that's what
a human being is and that's that's right
it's exactly right and that was the end
of his night terrors by the way which
seems too good to be true
but it is actually true because I
followed up with his mother for a long
time and that was that he catalyzed that
part of his identity he adopted the role
of the mythological hero and that's what
he needed to do because like there was
lots of dread there's a dragon and a
bunch of the works like what the hell
are you going to do about that run
that's not going to help you know if you
run in a dream like that
the doors multiply and they get bigger
and you get smaller as you run like
that's not a good that is not a good
solution and people do that in their
life all the time and so the dwarves get
bigger until they're giants and they get
smaller until there's nothing left of
them and then then there's no recovery
that is not good